it's that time again today we're
counting down on what i think are my
personal top 10 new anime from this
summer season comparing this to my
pre-season video i'd say that there are
some major surprises that the season
gave us it just shows us that it's never
too late to count something out without
further ado let's get the ball rolling
starting off we have the detective is
already dead
in my pre-season video i placed this
show as a top contender for anime of the
season having read some of the source
materials since then i stand by my words
however that would be if we're talking
source material because the adaptation
is being quite pedestrian to put it
lightly the show's definitely a
contender in the race for the most
polarizing anime of the season due to
some creative decisions made during
adaptation that's not to say that it
will become a bad show far from it in my
opinion that's why it's still here on
this list i think that as far as the
production side of things are concerned
such as the art the sound direction and
all of that sort of stuff the show is
still amazing as expected the mysteries
are still fun to follow and i still
applaud the chemistry between our main
duo of detectives however there seems to
be something when it came to translating
the emotions from the book into anime
form that and the unfocused genre seems
not to help matters for the general
audience overall i do really like this
show but i say that the adaptation can
use some work which is why the detective
is already dead is just number 10 on
this countdown
[Music]
up next is how a realist hero rebuilt
the kingdom
[Music]
[Music]
at first i had my eyes on this title
because of its somewhat different take
on the whole isekai thing instead of
taking the role of a powerful hero on an
adventure here we have a protagonist who
settles in for a more muted life as an
economist yep instead of the standard
action adventure scenes that we've all
grown used to seeing an isakai realist
hero does what it's advertised to do
giving a more down to earth take on the
concept of being reincarnated into
another world and it does really give me
a refreshing experience it's interesting
to see in isaikai through the lens of
someone who chooses to primarily employ
logic and economics in his rise to the
top the characters are also pretty
likable and i'd say that they're a big
part of the experience but it's not
without its flaws though i personally am
a fan of some itsakai tropes but i admit
that some may not be too hot on them
like the mandatory harem that seems to
be in every show of the genre these days
i also think that the world has been
fleshed out a lot better in the source
material but i just talked that up to
the standard compromises that have to be
done when a novel becomes an anime well
i'd say there's unfulfilled potential
here i'm content with what i saw out of
this anime sure it could be more and
politics is a different beast altogether
with its various layers and possibility
for turmoil and conspiracies but this is
a show that i have an overall positive
outlook of
[Music]
number eight on the list is sukimichi
moonlit fantasy now it's time for the
more traditional isakai well kind of the
thing is tsukimichi works like a more
light-hearted parody of the genre that's
the way i see it anyway it's an isakai
that's also a reverse isakai of sorts
mainly due to the parents background it
follows a lot of the tropes and story
beats that have characterized the genre
yet plays around with them wildly and
how it does its twists and turns and i
think that that makes it such a fun
watch for the general audience isakai
parody is pretty big right now and
tsukimichi is the perfect addition to
that ever-growing library of the
subgenre and i found the most joy in
seeing how makoto and his funny
companions interact with the world
overall tsukimichi is the more easygoing
isakai of the season that you might want
to pick up if you're looking for
something to kill time and unwind two
[Music]
when i saw the promo art for aqua top
and white sand several titles crossed my
mind there's just a feel to it that any
veteran fan would immediately recognize
and having pa works at the helm further
pushes that impression however what i
didn't expect is for aqua top and white
sand to be as straightforward as it was
now that's not a bad thing necessarily
i'm always up for a slice of life and
the story of a former idol reigniting
her passion for the joys of life is
something that i did have a good time
watching helping with the enjoyment is
seeing pa works pull out their a game
with how they made the backgrounds and
the overall atmosphere so vibrant and
alive the arts definitely the strongest
part of the show and it blows almost
every other element out of the water
people have called this a successor to a
lull in the sea or blossoms for tomorrow
and i can clearly see the similarities
if you're a fan of the aforementioned
series you should give this one a try
it's not nearly as dramatic as the
flagship key titles that people might
associate with the studio but it's still
as heartwarming in its own right
[Music]
coming in at number six is words bubble
up like soda pop and now we have a
surprise movie on the list bet you
didn't see this one coming now did you
for a whole lot of you the boy meets
girl's story of cherry and smile maybe
something that's quite familiar to you
two people coming together falling in
love while becoming each other's pillars
of support as they grow together it's
not the rarest anime movie out there but
this one still hits home when it matters
in letting its charm shine in making you
feel good the story develops like
various other movies of the genre but
the production and the chemistry between
the characters really get a chance to
take the forefront here while somewhat
formulaic the story still had my
attention as i followed the two
protagonists in their adventure in
search of an old record in terms of
visuals and sounds the film is simply
beautiful nowhere near shinkai level or
anything mind you but more than
serviceable enough for what you're
expecting to get in a feature film the
charming movie is available on netflix
for those who are up for some feel-good
road maps to spend the weekend with
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
remake on life is one of those shows i
was quite excited to watch i always
liked the premise of going back in time
to well remake my life and pursue the
passions that i once had the premise the
relatable setting of the gaming industry
and the art style caught my attention
and the healthy sprinkling of fan
service in the early episodes is just up
my alley my biggest experience with a
premise like this is with re-life and
i'd say that remake on life provides a
completely different tone and execution
with a similar story overall it really
feels like a wish fulfillment story with
a super adept and skilled main character
as they say overpowered but placed in
the context of a more realistic setting
i personally still find it a delight to
watch and the good points do click with
me i definitely recommend you try this
one out
[Music]
on
what happens when you put together the
brains behind interspecies reviewers the
artist behind dragon maid and studio
mappa yep it's either then deity's no
only peace at first glance the show
immediately looks like the brainchild of
the two creators and if you're expecting
a healthy mix of the series associated
with them then you'd pretty much be
correct i've not given the series its
proper pre-season welcome but i say that
there's not really much to unpack if
you're talking about the premise of
edith then deities god puts an end to
the era of demon centuries ago the new
generation doesn't know of those feats
and battles and it's up to the last
member of the old guard to train the new
misfits in the looming battle against
the resurrected demons it's pretty much
supernatural shonen given a very
colourful and wacky visual style thanks
to the two creators involved and of
course some raunchy content but what did
you expect it's pretty surprising to see
mapa work on a show with this visual
style after seeing a common thread among
their big hits but they've done a good
job with this all things considered i
find the show quirky and fun to watch
and if you look closely enough there's
been some clever world building amidst
the fighting and the fan service it
might not be the show now for everyone
but it's something that i'd recommend to
seasoned anime watches
honestly i didn't know what to make of
sony boy before the season started all
in all sony boy indeed is a visual
spectacle with a lot of thought and
meaning put into it i called sony boy an
artsy show and i think that by this
point you can tell the reputation of
something like that you know a show that
is dialogue driven filled with some
insights and thoughts about humanity to
go with its drama along with visuals
that can probably put any non-theatrical
productions to shame it also eschews
most of the high octane action that
often comes associated with the premise
of being lost in a dimension with
superpowers it takes things slowly and
methodically yes sony boy is a slow show
and it requires a lot of attention and
thought on the part of the viewer that's
to say that it's not a show for everyone
but it does have its niche and if you
happen to fall into said niche i think
that this show can be a strong contender
for anime of the season
ugh
talk about a surprise entry it aired
quite late into the season but fenner
pirate princess is quickly becoming the
rising star of the summer 2021 season
surpassing all expectations as i can see
i know the fact that i promoted it on
this channel a few videos back is not a
reason for me placing it as number two
on the list the show's legitimately good
in a lot of ways and it pretty much blew
away all expectations i had when i
started covering it at first glance it
seems to be a typical adventure
featuring a plucky girl on a quest for
treasure i mean i felt that way too
until i actually watched the show and
got enthralled by the adventure of
self-discovery it really does give some
yonah of the dawn vibes and i'm sure
that a lot of people have pointed that
out but to a lesser extent i can see
some of snow white with red hair and i
really enjoyed that show as well what i
like about fenner is that i can
immediately tell that the show's been
given the love and care that it deserves
during production that much can be
reflected in the visuals the detailing
and the background music for an anime
original by production ig this is
looking very promising even though it
hasn't had as many episodes as most of
its seasonal peers if you're out for an
adventure story with some themes of
family and self-discovery then our
pirate princess is definitely worth the
watch
foreign
[Music]
and here my friends at the top of the
list is a show that definitely didn't
disappoint in my preseason video i
praised the show to high heavens for its
unique visual appeal it's enchanting
music buys for yuki kajura aside and its
execution of the whole victorian europe
setting consider those expectations met
and i can confidently say that the case
study of vanitas is a legit contender
for anime of the season whether i take
into account my personal opinions or not
what starts off as a premise of a
mystery slowly unravels into a very
multi-layered story about some striking
themes chief among those the idea of
self-worth and guilt it helps that the
characters come with their own
complexities and intricacies even
characters portrayed to be eccentric
naive or goofy eventually reveal hidden
depths and those work so well with the
story that the narrative is trying to
tell us the complexity along with a
blend of serious and comedic elements
come together to create a show that can
be enjoyed by viewers of all tastes and
interests plus it's got a lot of good
looking guys for the girls while some
scenes have been cut from the manga as
usual i don't think that they really
detract from the experience here in
contrast to the detective is already
dead which i mentioned a while ago i
think the vanitas anime still manages to
capture the magic of the manga in its
own way and that's why i have this as my
number one new anime of summer 2021 all
right
[Music]
how's your list looking then comment
below and let me know i'd love to have a
chat with you about it if you enjoyed
the video don't hesitate to like the
video and subscribe to the channel so
that you can be notified the next time i
upload another video you may also
support the channel via patreon or
memberships and each contribution will
go a long way in allowing me to make
even better videos or giving you a
glimpse of my video making process
that's it for today i hope you had fun
watching and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you